starting today some teachers in Florida
can carry guns inside the classroom the
law was passed in response to the
Parkland school shooting last year 17
students and staff were killed but
critics worry this will make schools
less safe Manuel Bojorquez is in
parkland Florida and well how many
teachers are armed
well good morning the truth is we may
never know that number that's because
those teachers are supposed to remain
anonymous for their safety now school
districts can opt out of arming teachers
so there will be none here at Broward
County Public Schools but a handful of
other smaller school districts are all
in starting today students in bay county
schools along the Florida Panhandle may
be walking into a classroom where the
teacher is carrying a concealed handgun
bill Haas felt is the superintendent
everybody wants to know how do we
prevent it how can we stop it we don't
look at it as we want more guns we look
at it as we want more protection the
schools already have an armed resource
officer but the so called Guardian
program which had allowed some staff and
coaches to carry guns on campus after a
background check psychological exam and
more than 140 hours of range training
now extends to teachers for Huss felt
this is personal it's also in many ways
about an incident that happened in this
room
yeah that's correct I mean I was held
hostage by a gunman a praised gunman in
2010 a gun wielding man walked into a
school board meeting
eventually firing right at haasvelt and
others he missed and was shot by a
security guard before taking his own
life
you know experiencing that myself put a
different spin on it and a different
understanding about what goes on in
those situations you know until you're
standing in front of someone with a gun
pointing that you don't realize how
helpless you really are according to the
Education Commission of the states
Florida joins eight other states that
have laws allowing some teachers to
carry guns on campus critics include
family members whose loved ones died in
last year's parkland shooting themselves
like tonymont
so and Debbie Hickson montalto lost his
daughter Gina and Hickson's husband
Chris was the school's athletic director
teachers should not be burdened whether
they think they want to be or not with
the responsibility of worrying about
carrying a firearm they argue that
mental health programs and responsible
firearm ownership are better deterrent
to mass shootings and that armed
personnel should remain outside the
classroom we do believe in the Guardian
program we do believe in school resource
officers and we do believe in having
trained police officers on the campus we
need an armed person on the campus able
and willing to react properly some
critics also believe the state lacks
proper oversight of the program
including making sure that the teachers
training is sufficient we should point
out that the state's largest school
districts including those in Miami and
Orlando have opted out of the program
choosing instead to rely on armed
officers Gale men well thank you